the romantic narrative
um demands that the guy uh seeds powder
doesn't it that's what the
that's how the narrative works it's like
if you were if you really loved me then
you would do this you would do that you
would give up this you give up that
so it's it's it's about resisting that
societal programming
i have a question for you guys
i have a question for you guys one of
your opinions so that romantic narrative
do you think like that and maybe on an
unconscious level or whatever level
is pushed for women or for men
in other words like beta men who
gravitate towards that is like a option
for them whereas the other way of
thinking might not be
an option that they could consider or or
is it for
do you think it's just strictly for
women or both i don't know i mean yeah
both
guys i can sacrifice oh awesome i'll get
poon that way and the girl's like oh
he's gonna give me [ __ ]
hump sounds for it's a great lie because
everybody loses and wins at the same
time
it's the uh it's what i call the
cardinal rule of relationships which
are mating strategies cardinal rule of
mating strategies which is
for one sexes mating strategy to succeed
the other one has to either compromise
or abandon their their mating strategy
to some degree
so for it's usually for guys because
guys you know 80 percent of guys are
unattractive and they're trying to
figure things out that's why monogamy
works really well for them in marriage
and
at least in the past anyways it was it
was the ideal situation right
because she has to she you become the
head of household you
you know you reproduce but you still
have the responsibility
uh to your kids and alimony and
everything else if things go
south but um it is it was a good deal
for
guys who are simply not like sterling
cooper right they can't go and nail
like three girls in three different
countries and exercise their own
sexual strategy on their own for men
men's special strategy is what unlimited
access to unlimited sexuality
for women it is finding the best quality
guy who is going to not only be
you know alpha [ __ ] but beta bucks as
well and then for women
they can only they can only really
maximize alpha [ __ ] for
a 10-year span maybe whereas the rest
has to be beta bucks it has to be
long-term security has to be
protection provisioning and parental
investment and so they're trying to
balance those things
men on the other hand well men need
variety
we need variety it's just that we're
wired for unlimited access to unlimited
sexuality
so when you are trying to form a
balance between the two a compromise
between the two it's usually
if a guy is to fulfill a woman's mating
strategy which is i need you to be like
the guy who's parentally invested in me
he has to abandon his strategy for a
woman for a man to maximize his strategy
that means the woman
in in even sterling's case or maybe abu
americans case whatever
she has to abandon or compromise part of
her own strategy which is why
four wives hate each other because
they're all trying to
maximize their own strategy when the guy
is so high value
that he forces them to compromise their
mating strategy
so for one to succeed the other one has
to compromise has to compromise or
abandon
and today for the 80 percent of beta
males
they have to abandon it completely
that's why it's all responsibility and
zero authority because they've abandoned
it
if there was a compromise there where
the guy like i say this all the time you
know women love a man
they don't want a man to cheat but they
love a man who could cheat most
men can't can't possibly cheat there's
no opportunity there's no
there's no yeah they think it's a great
idea that they've got this one girl
who's willing to touch their dick
right that's their that's their whole
thing and i'll get kids out of it and i
can resolve my
my uh my reproductive problem no problem
they'll sign on even
even when they know that marriage is an
all
downside all risk uh risk proposition
for them
they'll still take it because that's
that's where they are in their heads
because we program these guys and
and you know blue pill conditioned them
to believe that that's the best thing
what they've done is abandoned entirely
their unlimited access to unlimited
sexuality except
when they're jerking off to porn and
sterling is entertaining them
you